plus que choqué franchement si je dois
le dire le fond de ma pensée si j'avais
été responsable de l'émission je
n'aurais pas invité maxime nicole je
suis un peu embarrassé partager un
plateau avec lui je le tiens à la fois
pour un individu très dangereux
je tiens à la fois pour un pauvre type
qui a exploité la crise des gilet jaune
pour devenir un gourou savez ce que ses
capacités naturelles ne lui aurait pas
permis de faire en d'autres
circonstances
et il se sert de ce poste de bourreau
qu'il a usurpé pour mettre des théories
de mer dans la tête des gens des
théories complotistes il avait de quoi
faire provoquer la troisième guerre
mondiale vous souvenez des théories à il
a inventé quelque chose même si nicole
il faut quand même rendre hommage c'est
le révisionnisme en direct à dire que
les cadavres de ces malheureux à
strasbourg était pas encore froid qui se
répandait avec des théories
révisionnistes et complotistes donc
voilà son métier maintenant c'est de
rester dans la lumière en en rajoutant
toujours en mettant le maximum de merde
dans le cerveau de gens qui sont
déboussolés certains qui sont vraiment
dans la détresse sociale dans la
détresse économique à chaque fois c'est
ses attentats sur la table c'est moi ou
alors je sais qu'il ya quelques semaines
à chaque fois on me pose des questions
là-dessus que c'est vous en direct à
venir même paré le dérive d'essence
parce que simplement vous n'existait que
médiatiquement dans n'existait que du
malheur des gens 5 soit les gens qui
sont dans la détresse sociale soit gagée
odirile de se faire assassiner
vraiment je suis pas fier de vous
maintenant je suis très embarrassé les
boules et moi je dois dire de plus pour
défendre quelque chose à la base c'est
des revendications de gilet jaune est
d'amasser sar ne referais ça fait
longtemps qu'on finit non ou alors le
bonheur avec des théories complotistes
révision regarder les chaînes de men
stream mais bon c'est pas après c'est
votre droit vous avez long de regarder
les chaînes d'information goulet moi ça
fait des semaines que je rabâche les
revendications des villes et jaune et
vous faites les sourde oreille en
essayant c'est la rectrice et lost c'est
un prévenu agents qui les gens qui
crèvent la dalle dans ce pays sans
prêter que oui vous vous en servez comme
avant ça vachement vous en foutez de ces
gens là bien sûr je vous rappellerai
cette affaire bemba situation légale
c'est henri scandaleuse bien sûr là bas
c'est votre avis et pas plus lent mais
c'est tout
on la compo n'est la mairie rené entre
ces personnages anonymes où on en est
30 40 des gens qui émergent en temps de
crise qui nous aucune valeur en eux
mêmes mais qui profite de ce temps d'une
nouvelle pour rester dans la lumière
votre problème ma main si vous avez
émerger de l'ombre maintenant vous
faites tout pour essayer de rester dans
la lumière sur le cd moi je suis décidé
à vous aider
très simplement qu'est ce que vous avez
dit ce que vous avez déclaré m de
personnes en fait la seule aide que j'ai
c'est le soutien des gens qui
considèrent que c'est révolu et s'amuser
mais c'est à mes frais semblant d'être
de votre côté mais vous exploiter leurs
malheurs et leur misère vous êtes un
imposteur
bien sûr c'est le train à poster un jour
ça éclatera au grand jour pour l'instant
que vous abusez encore des gens de moins
en moins j'ai l'impression mais les
derniers vous lâcheront et vous
retrouverez seul avec votre conscience
c'est votre rêve et votre petite machine
à buzz qui tournera à vide voilà sur
machine à buzz
c'est vrai que vous êtes une machine
boss des gens c'est une machine à buzz
vous en faites un aux pitoyables avec
votre façon de vous en faites un boss et
par mois respecté par tous les samedis
par exemple je suis en train de
manifester avec les gens devant les rues
d'arras et vous de champlon l'état vous
donner le change elle à l'express et
chez vous venez avec moi le samedi
devant les cas non car j'ai très envie
des travaux s'est déjà pénible d'être
avec vous ce soir je vais pas y passer
en plus conscients que vous voulez avec
monsieur zemmour c'est pas possible je
ne comprends pas là franchement
incitation à la haine raciale
condamné pour quoi que ce soit je parle
à mon grand regret l'invité c'est maximy
comme si vous n'habitez c'est pas que
maxime y colle c'est tout et vous des
intervenantes et moi et moi je vous dis
un truc que je préfère avoir je préfère
discuter que les gens moi je vous dire
j'ai connu maxime je vous dis quand il
était là et maxime on a discuté plein de
faux en loge ensemble moi c'était un
garçon vraiment je vous dis avec qui
vous pouvez discuter et toujours dit
qu'il est qui m'avait dit voilà moi je
suis là parce que je vois plein de gens
dans la merde je vois plein de gens qui
arrivent pas finir jean freddy le 11 du
mois eh ben ils sont en mission en
galère et j'ai envie de me battre pour
ça et ce à son discours m'avait plu au
début avant après oui oui mais pourquoi
pourquoi ça dérivés comme ça à vous pour
bien rouler au maximum
il fallait rester sur ses revendications
et pas aller plus loin